Hey there everyone; back in 2012 you may
recall I went on a bit of a- a Yahtzee
binge. It started with me recording a one
roll Yahtzee...
- 'I have done it,
this tape's about to end, but I've done it'
- And from there you all went a bit crazy
sending me your own versions
- '81 rolls. Holy cow!'
- 'Oh shoot!'
- Now even now, a few years later,
I'm still receiving one roll yahtzees
from you and I love getting them. I
thought I'd show you a few more today,
but to mark the occasion I thought I'd
also do something a little bit special
myself. Here I am attempting a one roll
Yahtzee, but this time not with five but
six dice - and six pink dice because- well,
that's a bit of a Numberphile trademark
isn't it? And I'm not just recording it,
I'm attempting to capture it with a
super slow-motion camera; and there's my
little chihuahua Audrey on hand of
course. But before we do that, let's have
a look at a few more videos that have
come in from you the viewers: here's
Caleb
doing the deed...and like a true
Numberphile he's also tallied all the
stats, every combination of four of a
kind three of a kind - love your attention
to detail Caleb. And Kerry, well she was
joined by her excited sister when she
defied the odds with 571 rolls.
- (Kerry: Oh my God!) [Excited screams]
Now of course another way to
defy the odds is
to go industrial; and that's what they
did at this school in New Jersey.
- [Mr Head:] Hello Numberphile,
hello Brady. I'd like
to introduce you to Mr. Heads math
class - everyone give a wave.
As much as we'd
love to roll one set of dice at a time,
due to the complexities of middle school
scheduling we don't have two and a half
hours to sit around doing this. So we're
gonna do this on a rapid-fire scale; 24
students at a time, and we'll see how
long it takes. Before we do, since we love
the sound of sharpies on brown paper,
everyone pick up your sharpie; make a few
squeaks - go!
Perfect. One of us will be the factory
worker in Willy Wonka, getting the golden
ticket.
Are we ready class? Okay grab! 24 - roll.
Grab. 48 - roll.
- [Brady:] And I think you get the
picture what's going on here, so let's
just fast-forward a little bit.
- 504 - roll! Grab!
- Yahtzee!
- Yahtzee! On the five- somewhere
around the 504th roll.
Everyone give a round of applause
to Dylan! And it
was with fours.
- [Brady:] Great work there. But now
let's get back to my six pink dice. But
before the moment of truth, here are a
few puzzles for those of you who like a
bit of homework: with six dice how likely
do you think one of these is? A straight;
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6?
Why don't you calculate the odds on that
one. Or how about the likelihood of five
of a kind, without the sixth matching
dice? But I'm not going to ask you to
calculate the odds of this: one dice
landing perched on top of another. But
here's the moment you've been waiting
for; the six dice - the six pink dice - one
roll Yahtzee at 1,600 frames per second.
It took me a little under 1,100 rolls I
think, that count's a
little bit unreliable.
If you missed our Yahtzee extravaganza
back in 2012 it's still there in all its
glory - links are on the screen and in the
video description. And a special shout
out and thanks to those people on the
screen at the moment; they're Patreon
supporters, they give a little bit extra
to Numberphile. We appreciate it.
And some of you this month have a few
little bonuses coming out in the post so
thanks a lot. Now where are the dice? What
do you reckon, 7 dice 1 roll Yahtzee?